it's official guys it's official
the book of boba fett is a spin-off
series i was under the impression
we might be doing something more along
the lines of some of mandalorian season
three will be about boba fett and then
eventually we'll go back to the actual
storyline because it said december 2021
that's why i was like well it was
mandalorian season three comes it should
come out around that time so it only
makes sense apparently
it's a spin-off and i'm a-okay with that
i think that's perfectly fine
so we don't know much details about it
obviously fenix sham will be in there
one of the big names that's being really
associated with it beyond john favreau
is actually robert rodriguez
and that is a big element to what gets
me very excited about this
because he directed chapter 14 the
tragedy
and that episode of boba fett that was
his reintroduction that was boba fett's
like this is the new boba fett
you guys are gonna love this boba fett
that's what it was right
it was awesome it was badass and i think
the most brutal violent episode we've
ever seen of the mandalorian
in terms of just gnarly smashing those
helmets
yeah like whenever john messes up an
upload or something
bam john what the hell i deserved that
it feels good every time feels good to
me too man
i know you're a bit of a masochist i am
that's okay
thanks daddy no problem you say this son
of mine
good bits we planned all these uh
bits boba bits my my i don't know why
the tone i've taken this whole video
it's been like this
sam jackson
because you're excited you're excited
because it is exciting
news i'm excited that rodriguez will be
doing it i imagine they'll be doing the
similar thing
the way how mandalorian gets different
directors per episode or in peyton
reed's case he gets two what directors
they'll be bringing on for the boba fett
series if any of the directors from the
mandalorian other than john favreau and
dave filoni
if any of those directors will come over
here to help direct an episode
obviously robert rodriguez will be doing
so as well with the way how that
post-credits scene went down where
he kills bib fortuna and he sits in the
throne and just imagining kind of that
gangster gritty world of tattooing
or just that side of the of the galaxy
dealing with these vicious thugs
gangs and whatnot the real underground
side of it
that's the part that gets me most
excited about robert rodriguez's
involvement
because i feel like he will really play
more in
to that level of grit you already see it
in the action scenes
in the episode he directed and i want to
get some more of that
i'm absolutely the most excited about
this because of robert rodriguez's
involvement i mean because a his episode
was terrific and b
it makes me really excited to see him
getting back onto this scale especially
on the heels of something like elita
which had
a lot of things it got right a lot of
potential but hasn't panned exactly
out it makes me excited to see him back
in a very science fiction
world like this again and it's one where
i'm like yeah of course it's got all the
star wars stuff
focus on boba fett which is just cool
anyway but yeah i i love
what his style brings in terms of yeah
the rough and tumble side
the dustiness but also the sleek
imaginative side too and yeah i mean in
terms of the continuity of the
mandalorian doing like a book of boba
fett we've done all these chapters in
the mandalorian book
makes sense that there's like a little
appendix book that goes with it
and i'm like okay what exactly will we
be exploring we don't know the details
of the plot with calling it the book of
boafet with really getting
even though we had the reintroduction
and we see how he got his armor back
through mandalorian season two it'd be
cool if we go back a little bit see how
we got out of the sarlacc pit the rest
of those adventures how he teamed up
with fenik shan
things like that are things that i would
want to see explored in this series i
think people get very much excited for
even with like bib fortuna it seemed
like he had a real agenda there towards
him
in that moment so maybe in the beginning
of this series we might even see a
little bit more of that conflict that he
has with before tuna to really develop
that so that way even him killing him
there makes him more rewarding and cause
that
also they did bring back before tuna so
i think it would be cool to get more of
him
in this in the boba fett series ella had
a little bit of feel feeling if you
brought him back for five seconds he
killed them up
and maybe now that actor will get a
chance to have a little bit more scene
so we can see
more of how it goes i i don't know if it
would be like full on you start off
where it's just the whole thing
starts from the beginning of him getting
out of the sarlacc pit or if you're kind
of doing a
present flashback kind of combining
episode a little bit like a lost
i mean i feel like that could be a cool
element if you get it sort of as a
memory of his and then you can also play
with perspective that way yeah how he
remembers these things it seems like
there's a lot of opportunity
to both touch on stuff we know about but
also fill in a lot of blanks both in the
past and in the present and i think
a question that also does arise from
this like and it sort of just happens
with the fact of
the shows that are all within this
mandalorian timeline like
rangers of the new republic or that's
what at least sounds like the ahsoka
series
because you know there's been theories
going around of
moff gideon possibly working with or
working for
admiral thrawn it's like it's all sort
of tying into like there's a star wars
universe it's all connected and there's
like this main
little subset of mandalorian universe
and it's all connected yeah you know
yeah so i and i am wondering um you know
will like mando
and grosgu show up in the boba fett
series will boba fett
and fennec sham will they show up in the
mandalorian season three you know like
letting their timelines um converge once
more
i would love that because partly too in
the tradition of the
shows and films that they are
attributing and borrowing
from that's you know the time
perspective in samurai movies and stuff
like that especially you'll
come back to a moment from a totally
different character's perspective and
see
a whole new light so i feel like yeah
you might be able to do
especially if you're gonna we have to at
some point see how he
you know uh what happened between him
and fennec shan for example and that's
an opportunity i can imagine where
maybe you will have some presence of
dinjaran and grogu
on the fringes of that episode or
whatever but focus
on a completely different situation in
the same place it just yeah it's one of
those things that makes the geography
and the
history feel that much more tangible
yeah i'm like i'm really looking forward
to this i feel like i'll have a bit of
that like
outlaw vibe yeah you know the western
vibe is something that's very much in
the mandalorian but having more of that
gritty outlaw western vibe which
something like
rodriguez is perfect for this even
thinking about the twisters what i'll
say here in this video the twister and
from dusk till dawn how that all took
place at the bar and then here you got
jobless palace instead you know like
this just seems like the perfect laying
ground for this guy that's probably like
the main thing i'm looking forward to
relishing in
is the tone of this one
i imagine that with mandalori like i
think if you were to do mandalorian
season three
it is boba fett's show for the first few
episodes
it would just feel like a very different
series not just because of character
focus but also
mood and tone even with that
post-credits scene
you're like that feels so different
yeah than the man the lord it feels like
its own little isolated
thing within that greater context so it
has to be but
i'm excited for it i think it's gonna be
a great time boba fett's getting the
treatment the fans have been demanding
for so long now he's gonna craft the
high table for the star wars right
right all right guys well the boba fett
series are you excited for it leave your
thoughts down below you can subscribe
click that notification bell hit the
like button last but not
least
you know who gets a revival shout out
this month it's a nissan olympia
the book of venison because last month
we did not shout you out when you
absolutely deserved it
you know and i blame my fiance it's her
fault
always her fault especially when she's
not here to you know rebuke
us or to defend herself she said oh you
can't hear me
you want to shout out to me not in my
house all right i don't say most things
i don't either i've never spoken to
olivia in person actually but anissa
i want to tell you you have helped make
this year feel like christmas
all year that's very literal you're the
santa claus
you guys have no idea how many gifts she
sent our way you are so caring and
nurturing we have
so many gifts that i look like a hoarder
at this point
i'm like i have to keep and cycle
through all of them or else you're gonna
think i don't appreciate them
so mrs claus sexy
mrs colon north pole gas station
[Music]
what's in there
[Music]
you